malaria has killed more people than all
wars throughout human history combined
thanks to eradication efforts it is far
less common than it once was but every
year
malaria still kills a quarter of a
million children the most vulnerable
group in Africa alone
but again and again the disease has
become resistant to the treatments used
to defeat it malaria cases start in
humans with a bite from certain kinds of
an awful ease Gambian mosquito during
the bite malaria parasites are injected
into the bloodstream and travel to the
liver in this next stage they multiply
and rupture liver cells then they infect
red blood cells destroying them
anti-malarial drugs work by attacking
the malaria parasite in the blood cells
but the malaria parasite has adapted
time and again it has formed resistance
to some of the most powerful anti
malarial drugs from Chora Queen Tamiflu
Queen
malaria's ability to resist drugs is one
of the reasons success in eradicating it
has leveled off new ways to tackle
malaria are being developed seeking to
wipe out the mosquitoes that carry the
disease a gene editing technology called
CRISPR is being used to engineer a gene
Drive this creates selfish genes that
are always passed on to offspring the
aim is to interfere with fertility by
driving a gene for sterility through an
entire population as it is passed from
generation to generation the population
would be swamped with insects that are
unable to reproduce in theory they could
be driven to extinction last year a team
at Imperial College London successfully
created a gene Drive that wiped out
enclosed cohorts of one species of
malaria carrying mosquitoes but there is
no guarantee that gene drives could work
in the many environments where malaria
is found in the world especially in
Africa humanity has shown that it can
control malaria it has been eradicated
in around 35 countries currently the
best hope lies in a combination of
methods but in the future a gene drive
may be the most effective solution
coming up next
should we screen for lung cancer
you